We're now ready to take a look at some interior lighting or artificial lighting.
And just like I did with the natural daytime lighting, I wanted to go ahead and take a
look at some of the required versus optional tools they might have to use.
So in the case of man-made lighting, we will need at least one or more man-made light sources,
so a point light, spotlight, or rectangular light, or a rect light.
And then optionally, depending on your setup, a daylight type setup adjusted for moonlight,
so this would require at least directional light and a sky atmosphere.
A sky lighting to contribute to the rest of the global illumination.
A sky dome for backdrop visuals and volumetric clouds.
As well as if we want to use IES profiles for our man-made lights, should we need it.
So I think let's go ahead and open up our level here.
And just like I've been doing before, just so you know, I'm opening the bunker underscore night level.
And just like I did with the other levels, I'm going to go ahead and delete most of the lighting in here.
So let's go ahead and delete all these.
Delete all this lighting information.
And in this case, you can see we still have some lighting information coming from this sign.
And this is because we're using emissive materials that contribute to lighting.
One of them is on a decal, so let's go ahead and delete that.
And we'll assign the red material that we have here to the Bernese image here,
just so we get rid of most of the lighting.
Now, one thing I'm not going to do is recreate the daylight setup,
because it's just essentially a daylight setup like we did before, but with moonlight.
Now, one thing that is slightly unique about this is that the sky atmosphere is accommodating right now for two directional lights,
one for the moon and one for the sun.
And by default, when we create an environment light mixer setup,
it just gives us something that's like nice daytime around 2 p.m.
In this case, if you were to create it, you might have noticed that while I was creating it,
I was skipping one of the atmospheric lights.
That's the one that you add to include a moon in there.
So you can see we've got one directional light for the sun and one directional light for the moon.
Now, the only thing that's really important for you to know if you're going to go for a setup like this
is that the moonlight needs a different index to the sunlight.
So all you need to do is select the light search index
and make sure that the atmosphere sunlight index is set to one for your moon
and set to zero for your sun.
Okay, once you've done that, we're ready to go.
So let's go ahead and let's take a look at some of the options or tools that we have to light interiors.
So first of all, we've got a point light, which is another light.
I know I've kind of gone over this a little bit before, but let's go ahead and go over it again.
So our point light emits light from a point in all directions.
And let's go ahead and bring the attenuation down on this one.
I'm going to bring it to like 300.
I'm going to bring it close to the wall so we can take a look at.
We're going to go ahead and change the temperature here to make it a lot more blue.
And ways in which we can control the look of this is of course the source radius.
So we can change the size of that specular highlight.
If you go bigger than the actual bounds of the attenuation,
you'll notice that it's suffering some ugly pixelation.
So try to avoid that.
But with this size, let's go ahead and set it to the size of two or something like that.
And then we can also change the source length.
So the length of the actual source of light.
So if I rotate this 90 degrees, we can bring it over to the wall
and get a sort of tube lighting setup.
Now the intensity of this is way too strong, so let's change it to something like one.
So now you can sort of see I've got a tube light setup with a point light.
Now remember, this is a light that's shooting light, sorry, light in all directions.
So it's a little bit more expensive than if you were using something a little bit more directional.
Say for example, a spotlight.
So if I add a spotlight in here, and sorry, I'll re-add that since it went somewhere a little bit weird.
So I've got a spotlight in here.
And you can see the tool that I have in my disposal to edit this.
First of all, let's go ahead and make it moveable since we're using Lumen.
And second of all, we can change the outer cone angle to change the actual shape of the light.
You can change the inner cone angle to change the hardness of the light.
So this is a little bit like that inner radius or source radius, but defining the cone itself alone.
You can also change the source radius, so the actual source of the light.
Let me bring this a little bit closer to the wall so we can see the difference there properly.
You can see how it changes the source radius, changes that specular highlight once again.
And you can also change the source length.
Let's go ahead and we're actually going to use this to start lighting this since this is a little bit of a spotlight.
So I'm going to change the temperature here to maybe 4000 Kelvin.
I'm going to move it around there.
And I could start editing the outer cone and inner cone to get some nice results.
Oh, what I think I'm going to do, I'll make the outer cone a little bit wider.
But what I think I'm going to do is actually use an IES profile.
So let's go ahead and scroll down to the IES section and under IES, I'm going to grab this number 10.
It's a pretty nice shape. Let's try with this one.
And I think these are all a little bit dark on one side.
So I think I'm going to go with this number 10 one here.
And let's go ahead and change the attenuation of the light to make sure that we're reaching the right amount.
So the attenuation is quite big here.
So let's go ahead and maybe try with 550.
And now what I'm going to do is duplicate the lights and place it around.
So I'm going to hold Alt and then move it around.
So I'm going to hold Alt and then move.
And then Alt again to duplicate and move the light.
There we go. It's time to get some some lighting in our scene.
I'm also going to add a spotlight for this light over here, this big one in the middle.
So let's go ahead and add a spotlight there.
And then I'm roughly placing these.
In this case, I think I'm going to get rid of the IES profile.
So I'm going to clear it here.
I'm just going to make the outer cone much wider.
Like so. Same for the inner cone.
Just to give it a bit more strength.
And I'll bring the attenuation radius up so it's a little bit stronger.
Just might bring the intensity down to something like five.
So we don't flatten the scene out too much.
Maybe three. There we go.
Now we have a little bit of lighting information for everything.
So that's how we can control spotlights.
The next light that I want to take a look at is a rectangular light.
And we're going to take a look at it with this TV thing that we've got going on here.
But for that, I'm going to delete these two lights.
Just so that we have a little bit of a darker scene to play with.
And for something like this, we want to be using a rectangular light or a rec light.
So let's go ahead and drag this in.
And I just rotate it and essentially make it match the actual shape of the TV.
So let's go ahead and bring it closer to the TV.
Place it as central as I can.
I'm just eyeballing this.
And in this case, I can change the source radius.
Sorry, the source width and height to edit the way this looks.
So let's go ahead and just roughly make it the size of the TV here.
And now depending on the light that you have,
you can actually change some attributes of this rectangular light to be more interesting.
So for example, the barn door angle, if the light needed to be kind of contained a little bit to
change its shape and the barn door length.
So you can sort of see how you can affect the light there.
In our case, I think we actually want these to be flattened
since it's just a flat screen TV.
It's got a little bit of an angle, so let's try and match that.
We'll turn off the angle snap.
Match the angle.
There we go.
Turn these back on.
So now, okay, we have something that's pretty good,
but the light color is not matching the actual light of the color of the image.
And the intensity as well.
So let's go ahead and change the intensity to something like four.
And then I could manually change the color to something close.
I could even color pick a color from there and match as good as I can.
I could also just manually match the color myself
to something that makes a little bit more sense.
But actually, one of the nicest features about this rectangular light
is that you can actually use a source texture to texture the light itself.
So I'm going to go ahead and use the texture that is being used on that screen.
Let me go ahead and show what happens.
So this is the texture that's on the screen.
I'm going to go ahead and drag it into source texture.
And you'll see it's lighting, but it's actually almost too perfect, right?
It gives us too much of an accurate representation of the image.
So usually what we do is use a blurred light texture.
So it's the same texture as the original, but it's blurred.
And using that, you can see we get a really nice realistic effect
of what the TV is actually lighting up.
And again, this still works with all your intensity controls,
so you have nothing to change there.
There we have it.
We've looked at all the sort of man-made light systems that we have.
Now, the last thing that I wanted to cover is emissive lighting.
So I'm going to go ahead and once again, just delete all of our work
and get rid of these lights.
We'll leave these.
And take a look at how we can use emissive materials to change lighting.
So for example, if we go to the material section here,
you'll notice that we have an emissive material here that's emissive.
If I drag this onto the object, you can see that it starts emitting light.
Now, there's a couple of things that you need to worry about with emissive lighting
is that the quality isn't as good as using the emissive material.
It's as good as using actual lights.
So it's best to actually rely on proper lights to do the work for you.
But it might be handy in a couple of different situations.
And by the way, of course, this is all dynamic
and works exactly the same as you'd expect.
So in this case, I'm going to go ahead and keep that with the red color
and I'm going to assign this material to our burnie sign.
Now, you'll notice that this does affect things and it is lighting things up,
but you might not be getting the full effect that you need.
So in some cases, you need additional information
to actually get the final result that you want.
In our case, we're going to need a rectangular light
to project a little bit more light coming out of this.
So let's go ahead and add a rectangular light.
I'm going to turn it around just like before.
Place it in the correct place.
I think this might actually be rotated a bit.
Place it here.
And again, I'm just going to roughly match that shape.
And I will be changing the attenuation.
So it's not strong.
Say something like this.
And we'll change the color to this sort of neon red
that we've got going on here.
So we have the light that it's producing.
But you can see we don't have any lighting information on this side here.
And for this, we might actually have to use a decal actor.
So I'm going to go ahead and bring a decal actor in.
And a decal just allows us to project a material or an image onto a surface.
Now, they're really good for things like dirt and things like that,
but they can also be used as lighting if they use a massive material on them.
So let's go ahead and put the emissive material on it for the decal that we have here.
And we're just going to project it, if I rotate it here,
onto our image.
And I'm just going to essentially rotate it and scale it to the right position.
Go a little bit smaller.
And you got to be careful when scaling because you might scale it too much and
you won't be able to actually see it on the wall.
So you just have to keep nudging.
There we go.
We have something that matches our image here and starts to produce light as well.
So that really is all the techniques that we need to color for interior lighting.
And really all the techniques that we need to cover for this whole introductory video.
So I hope that you've learned a lot and I hope that you had fun with me
and I'll catch you in the next one.